I'm going to explain how to un your
business there are six problems that
most businesses present with I own a
portfolio of companies at acquisition.
comom that do over $250 million a year
and I see business owners at our
headquarters all the time whether we're
looking to invest in the business or
they're just looking for help and so
these six problems plague many many
businesses so in this video I'll show
you how to solve them the right path to
take and one example of a portfolio
company that we actually walk this
through so number one is serve too many
avatars so what does that mean so if you
don't know what an avatar is by the way
an avatar is just like a ideal customer
profile ICP there's different you know
there's different language in different
Industries what they call it but
basically who are you trying to serve
who's your customer and who's your daddy
anyways and so serve too many avatars
basically means that you're just saying
yes to anyone with money and not
necessarily saying yes to only those
people who you can deliver the most
value to Andor who can pay the prices
that you want to charge and so this is
fairly common especially when you're
starting out call it you know sub $3
million a year uh in Revenue because in
the beginning you're just saying yes
anyone who's got money right you're just
saying oh he's got a credit card
therefore he is qualified right and it
that that can that can obviously create
issues in the short term for you now the
reason for that is because when you sell
to too many different people you have
too many different expectations that
have to be set on the front end so it
makes your marketing less effective
because you have to be everything to
everyone which means you're nothing to
no one uh on a on a sales perspective
it's more difficult to train sales teams
because they have to be trained on many
different prospects and potentially many
different versions of the product uh
with different expectations being set
for for each one of them that can be
really complex on the third level like
if that weren't enough like really hard
marketing really hard sales the third
piece is that your team that does
delivery then has to get trained on all
these different types of delivery for
all these different types of avatars and
again the reason that people still keep
doing this is because they always need
to make payroll they always need to make
pay make rent and they're afraid if they
turn customers away who are less
qualified that they're not going to be
able to do it so by doing avoiding the
short-term pain of actually being like
you know what these are the customers
that we do well with these are the ones
we don't and we need to get more of
these uh and we're willing to have a
short-term loss in order to really
establish the business uh people just
stay in this like everything to everyone
land which sucks and so when I say
narrow the front end I mean that the
messaging and the lead magnets or the
things that you offer people in your
advertisements whether that's through
outbound through content through paid
ads or even through Affiliates if you're
giving you give something away in order
to get people's information you call
them up you sell them whatever you want
to make sure that that's narrower if I
say hey the hair industry here's a free
report on the hair industry that's going
to get anyone in the industry if I say
how to get your first five uh hair you
know cut and color clients I'm going to
probably I might get some salon owners
but I'll probably be skewed heavily
towards hair stylists if I said how to
fill up your hair salon and get all 10
of your chairs filled within 30 days
then I'm going to have a much I'm going
to skew harder towards salon owners and
so the messaging the call out that you
have in the ad if you say attention
salon owners then you'll get Salon if
you say attention hair stylist you'll
get hair stylist if you say I'm going to
help you fill your salon you'll get more
salons like hope this makes sense but
you get narrower in your messaging but
here's the thing that everyone's afraid
of this is the big fear here if I get
narrower in my messaging I'm going to
get fewer leads yes and no if you get
narrow when you're messaging you will
have a higher response rate in general
from that particular segment and so
sometimes the LTV toac ratio actually
expands it gets even better when you
because then you don't have the smaller
one that you're diluting it down with
and all of your focus and the um copy
gets so much crisper for that person and
they think this is what you want them to
think when they see your ad oh this is
just for me oh rather than like I might
find some value here that's the
difference yeah and so um because I talk
a lot about marketing stuff I I tend to
have a lot of marketing agencies um that
follow my stuff as well and if I were to
invest in a marketing agency I would
want one to be in a vertical I'd want it
to be in a niche I'd want to buy an
agency that only Services painters I
want to serve one that only Services
plumbers not one that just says like if
you run ads we do that um it's just much
it's just it's just harder it's just
it's too many things to too many people
so the fix here is you look at the LTV
toac you see the one that has the
greatest discrepancy relative to how
much how big the market is and then you
cut one of the front ends to the one
that you get the best uh return on ads
spend and then either you bridge to the
second or cut the second off so the
second Horseman of our our business
apocalypse is underpriced and so this is
where you charge too little to be able
to scale your business and so most
people when they pick how much they're
going to charge they just look at the
maret Marketplace they take the average
and say I'm going to do a little bit
more value for a little bit less money
and that's how they pick but the thing
that they don't know is that everyone's
broke that's the fun fact is that the
average business owner makes very little
money and um takes on a tremendous
amount of risk in order to make very
little money and so um what I want to
walk you through is kind of a a
three-phase plan for for getting out of
this particular scenario okay and so
fundamentally you have two types of
customers you've got the existing
customers and you've got the new
customers
so we're actually going to solve these
in kind of a reverse order so your
existing customers are the ones that you
already have these the people who pay
you every month or they continue to come
back whatever the second is new
customers these are the people who are
the leads right now who will eventually
become customers in the future now when
we actually want to make a pricing
change we actually do it like this we
want to do new customers first and then
existing customers second and I'll
explain the process and so when you do
the new customers here's how it works
you just raise your price
that's it you just raise your price
that's all you have to do is that when
you get to the point on the script where
you would normally say hey it's $1,000
you just say hey it's $1,500 or it's
$2,000 and one of the things that people
don't understand is that you will get
more
nose but you can also make more money
and so let me walk you through this so
let's say that we doubled our price and
let's say our close rate before this was
we were closing uh 30% of people that we
get on the phone with okay now if we
doubled our price and our Clos rate drop
to
20% that's a great deal we should do
that every day while still getting more
NOS than we were before and this gets
difficult for people to wrap their heads
around especially entrepreneurs because
we and sales people like you want to get
yeses and it hurts to get rejection but
you just have to let this be a math
problem and then solve for it now let's
say that you get on the front end and
you make this change and if the market
accepts that change they bear the higher
cost or the higher price that you want
to switch to that then gives you day to
to go to your existing customer base now
I'm not recommending that you just say
hey guys I just raised prices good luck
that will surely piss a lot of people
off so instead what we do is uh we have
a we have a process that you basically
want to walk through so number one is
you're going to send them an email
saying that something big is going to
come so you just give them a little bit
of like brace yourself so you just like
a little brace right uh big news coming
tomorrow um just letting you know
whatever B then in the email itself what
you want to do is number one straight to
it just let them know that you're going
to be raising the prices number two then
tell them that this is not because
you're a greedy bastard but because you
want to fulfill promises and you see
that you're no longer fulfilling the
promises that you originally promised
them and in order to reinvest in the
business that's going to get them a b c
benefit as a result of this investment
because they don't care about you or
anything they just care about what what
is it w ifm uh what's in it for me so
you just have to explain to them that
you're going to be taking this money
you're going to be reinvesting in them
and what they're going to get as a
result now uh before this we do the
little reminder sorry I forgot to
include this uh of value which is hey
you've been with us for X period of time
and we've made you this much money we've
saved you this much time we've cut your
grass this many times we've gotten this
you know you left at these reviews you
want to demonstrate or remind them of
the value they've already provided them
then you tell them the bad news then you
put that bad news in context of the
promises that they're going to get then
and this is the this is where you soften
the blow and so you soften the
blow by saying hey I already raised the
price on these [__] these new guys
who haven't been here for a while I've
already raised the price on them but
because you're and you have been a loyal
customer I'm going to give you a
discount for the next 3 to six
months on that original price and so the
new price is effective today that's when
you say that it's straight here but like
slow down I'm going to give you a
discount equal to your current payment
for the next 6 months and then after
that point you will then go up to the
regular price and that's as a reward or
a thank you for being so loyal and so
you give them the price raise but you
soften the price raise with the discount
and then people are much more
comfortable having a discount disappear
than a price go up and so also we're
extending out when the Pain's going to
happen and so it's like you give them
the news today but then you're like oh
no no don't worry doesn't affect you
today it's going to affect you in the
future future use problem right and so
that again this softens the blow and
then finally you want to have a little
PS statement that at the end you say hey
by the way and this humanizes you you
say hey by the way um if you're going to
go homeless because of this this price
increase if you're not be able to afford
groceries if this is going to materially
affect your business if you're B2B just
please reach out to me I would love to
like get on the phone with you and we'll
figure out something that's it and so
then the thing is is most people when
they read that you're going to have one
or two like most people read that be
like h i get it if you're B2B they're
like he's a business owner I get it
whatever if it does materially affect
their business then they can get on the
phone and maybe you can extend it
another 6 months or you can ratchet it
up more slowly or you can peel off a
piece of the service that you offer them
um so basically it's like you have price
in terms and so it's like you can shift
the terms to make the original price
still just as profitable for you without
having to deliver as much uh value per
se to the customer and so this is kind
of like this is a quick and dirty
process um for walking through this now
if you have like a community or
something like that where you make this
uh post and i' I've walked a lot of
businesses through this uh when you make
the post just turn off comments and say
hey we want to keep this IRL so in real
life so if you have any questions please
reach out to me this is not going to be
a gossip Fest just hit me up I'd love to
talk to you all right and so um this is
how we solve the underpriced problem and
if you're curious about how this process
works I actually have a letter inside of
my gym launch Secrets book that walks
gym owners how to walk through a price
increase because many of them are
underpriced because they're like like I
did this for passion and they realize
that they make no profit um and so and
you can't expand your passion if you
make no profit and so I've walked
hundreds of of gyms through this and and
you know countless other businesses but
like I have walked through price raises
on uh recurring customers which is
significantly tougher than what just
simply raising a price on customers that
are onetime purchase if you're a onetime
purchase one like don't even worry about
it just raise the price you'll be fine
and if you need to adjust it later then
just peel something off if you if you go
too high and all of a sudden your Clos
rate drops too too low that actually
doesn't make sense just back down one
and just give those guys something extra
that's it so the third land ofy
is
overcompensation so this is kind of like
the sister of underpricing and the
reason this is so tough is that it's the
equal opposite instead of saying you're
not pricing high enough it's saying I'm
paying too much my cost of goods is too
high and so if you have physical
products you might have less wber room
in terms of your cost unless you have
some sort of massive breaks around
volume as you you know scale and you get
a iies of scale um but with a service
business and this is where it typically
happens is you have a new founder who
does some sort of rev share profit share
deal with what I would consider
high-skilled labor and in so doing
they're like yeah yeah I just do I just
do go 5050 with my therapists or
something like that but the therapists
aren't responsible for the overhead
they're not responsible for the cost of
requiring customers they're not
responsible for retaining customers they
don't do anything besides show up and
like crack backs or whatever right and
when you're in one of those situations
it's tough and so the reason there's a
lot of reasons it's tough but you
actually kind of want to go through the
same price raise concept but you're just
doing it on the employee level and
except it's a decrease instead of an
increase and you just basically I'll
walk through the same steps so it says
existing so this works out fine so
existing employees and so you brace them
and say hey I've got something serious I
want to talk to you about and say listen
we've worked together for this long
period of time so this is reminding them
of the value they pride in your life I
made you this promise that I want to do
this um but I'll get straight to it this
business isn't profitable and I can't
give you the career growth that I
ultimately promised you in the beginning
because we're never going to be able to
expand and we can't help more people and
the mission that I sign signed you on
was that we want to make you know this
Clark County healthy and we can't do
that because I made a mistake and that's
on me but and Lea puts this joke in
there which is um and uh and
unfortunately I can't get fired because
I'm the boss so I own the business I
still have to be here and so what I want
to do is kind of walk you through some
of the changes that are going to come
down the line so you're going to skip
this promises one because you're not
getting more money to reinvest right
you're going to go here which is um we
have to make this change to compensation
and you can give them obviously this is
going to be a little bit more individual
so here's my big disclaimer across the
video is that if you have somebody that
you have been with for a long time and
they have a family kids whatever and you
need to make this change then I suggest
giving them a period of time and saying
hey I'm going to put this change in
place in 3 months or 6 months and that
way if you need to look for alternative
employment you can do that but that
gives you some time now I would also
have a way
where I want you business owner to
answer this question what would it take
for them to be able to make the same
amount of money that they're currently
making because often times what has to
happen is a resetting of expectations
which is there probably is a way that
they could make what they're currently
making just not doing what they're
currently doing and so if you can
outline a plan for them which is hey if
you do these three things I can get you
back to here because this is how it
generates enough Revenue in the business
so that I can keep this promise to you
originally and so basically they have
three options option one they can just
say I don't want to work more and I'm
happy to stay here and that's fine cool
option one option two um I'm going to
take the three to six months but I'm
going to interview with some other
people fine option three uh I'm actually
going to work more I'm going to take you
up on this kind of changing the terms
offer and I would like to keep my
current current POS you know current
compensation and I will take on this
extra workload and so uh you can walk
them through each of those paths uh but
I will also say that you have to be
prepared for the fact that some people
will leave and so if you recall what I
said earlier you want to test this on
new customers first right well you also
want to test this on new employees first
if you put out a job you know job wreck
on a job board and you have the new
compensation structure in place go
recruit somebody go bring someone in go
have them do the same job as that other
person and if you can attract the same
level of talent that meets the standards
that you have then you know that you
were mispriced you were overcompensated
and then you can and then here you can
point to precedent right the key is on
both of these scenarios it's like you
try it with something new you make sure
it works and then you can go back and
say see I'm not being
unreasonable and so from there this also
is your insurance for the employees in
the business because you say hey if this
guy does leave I already hired one or
two people so that I can slot them in
and so again best case scenario you keep
the best talent and you can bring
somebody else on and save money on the
new people or uh you have to shuffle the
whole team out which unfortunately it
sucks it also happens and the
alternative is you never grow your
business and I want I want to be clear
if this is almost my always my least
favorite of the of the levers that I
have to pull I would so much rather
solve it by fixing the business model
and say like is there a way where we can
uh you know increase the price can we
get more upsells can we you know do
something something like that but where
this really gets tough is when you're
giving percentages of Revenue because
you can't business model fix it because
if you go make if you go fix the pricing
and fix the up so the person is just
getting basically a free raise for no
value provided that's where it gets
tough so it's less likely when you have
someone who's on maybe a salary or
someone who's hourly uh that you have to
go through this it's just in my
experience it's usually when someone is
giving someone some sort of Revenue
share or profit share on not the whole
business and I mean sometimes worst case
it's the whole business um but even just
like the revenue that they're maybe just
delivering on but they're not
accountable for any of the other costs
associated with it and so that's just
like kind of big red flag especially if
you're starting out of business I
wouldn't recommend doing that um unless
this is like they're a partner in the
business and it's an equity deal which
is just different and also the other
exclusion here and this is why you know
generic advice is tough um if you have
like a brick and mortar location for
example having a manager who's getting
10% of profit or something like that if
it's on bottom line then that person's
incentivized it's fine it's again it's
where when when you're taking it off top
top line how much sales you get
independent of costs that's where it
gets tricky I think the reason that so
many business struggle with compensation
is one just like pricing they just kind
of like look around and then just like
charge the average um which is not a
good way to set up compensation the
second is that when you are a smaller
business the percentage Revenue that
each additional hire is is a huge
percentage of the money of your net
profit they say your biggest expenses
walk on two feet so let's say that
you're a business that makes $1 million
per year which is great right now let's
say you run 25% margins okay so that
means that you're making
$250,000 per year after all your
expenses all right now let's say that
you want to hire one employee for
$100,000 a year all of a sudden you go
from $ 250 to 150 in terms of net income
and so this one hire takes up 40% of the
profit of your business and so the
reason that overhead walks on two legs
is that in the beginning your margin for
error on hiring because it's one of the
most expensive things you can do is very
small think about it like this if you
were to go sign up for a software for
$100,000 a year you would Google
consumer affairs you look at every
single review you get like seven
different demos to make sure that it did
exactly what you want but then you hire
this person after one conversation you
had at lunch because a friend of yours
made the introduction it's dumb and so
you got to be extra careful especially
when you're starting out and what hires
you're bringing in and what the true
output of increasing profit and bottom
line is and so let me put this in one
more context for you this person to pay
for themselves is going to have to
generate $400,000 per
year if your margin stay the same just
to cover the $100,000 that they cost you
and so if you can't see a clear line to
how they're going to add $400,000 in
Revenue to the business so that after
your 25% margins you have the 100,000
that's just break even and this is why
so many people get stuck yeah and the
brutal the brutal truth is uh typically
during 1 to three million in Revenue uh
we you know Leila and I refer to that as
the swamp and it's a swamp because you
need to be able to hire that $100,000
your employee but you can't afford to
and so you basically have two options
you either need to basically kill your
profit and bet on the fact that this
person's be able to generate that
Revenue so they can make up for
themselves in growth which realistically
means that they should replace almost
all the time that you're currently
spending on the business so that you can
then go rainmate go out there and go
hunt and bring more business in or you
have to just do that and work two jobs
you have to work your current job and
the next job and so you basically work
overtime and so the first version of
this uh you make no money and you bet on
the person the second version you
stretch yourself thin to be able to
create the profit extra so that you can
slide that person in without risking the
biscuit so number four is
overextension which is AKA The Woman in
the red dress and
so I use this is probably my most used
analogy that I have in all the business
content I have which is if you're new to
the channel if you've seen The Matrix
there's a training program where Neo the
main character is getting trained on
what the Matrix is and so he's walking
through and he's walking with Morpheus
who's the the guide and he says um were
you listening to me or were you looking
at the woman in the red dress and he
turns around and there's uh he says so
look again and so as soon as you looks
back at this beautiful woman in the red
dress who walked past him while he's
going through this training program and
not paying attention he looks back and
there's a gun point in his face and then
morphe says freeze and so he freezes the
program he didn't know that he was in a
simulation he says if you're not one of
us you're one of them and those are
agents and so women in the redress look
attractive they distract you from the
main thing but if if if if it's not one
of you if it's not the core business
it's something that's been sent to
destroy you and so I am so adamant about
this particular one because me as an
entrepreneur of the of the six that I'm
going to go through it's the one that I
have struggled the most with um I have I
have made so many mistakes with
overextension my eyes being bigger than
my stomach and I'm 13 14 years into
entrepreneurship now and I I honestly
feel like I'm still just learning this
lesson and so I I share this with you as
a as a cautionary tale because you can
always especially if you're good at
sales you're good at promoting you can
sell yourself and you can sell your team
on why this time it's different on why
it's not a shiny object and why it's
such an opportunity and so I want to I
want to give you this little lesson that
Leela gave me that I just continue to
think about over and over again if you
look at the things in your business that
you want to invest in the things that
you stress your team out over are they
missed opportunities are they things
that you think you should be doing but
you aren't or are they problems are they
things that you that you've promised but
you're not delivering as well as you
should have and if you want to have uh a
great framework around this which I will
give to you is you will grow bigger by
getting better you will not grow bigger
by choosing to get bigger when you
choose to get bigger you will get
bloated and so you grow through
Improvement I have this this Frame that
I've just been working on that's
probably I'm make a whole podcast about
it but I'll give you the the the quick
and dirty if you want to make something
valuable fundamentally you have the
promise or the claim that you have so
you say hey I'm going to help you with
XYZ if people say I want that that is
all you need you now have a valuable
claim all right everything after this
point is removing friction and so you
have to think what are the things that
make this suck delay makes this suck
effort that they now have to do this is
new things they have to do that they
don't want to do as a result of the
purchase sacrifice what are the things
that they have to stop doing that they
wish they could keep doing as a result
of the purchase risk which is what risk
do I now have to incur so B2B for
example if you have to start spending
money on ads that's a new risk that you
have to incur if you start with an
agency on top of the agency itself if
you have a a travel uh membership where
people go to houses it's like well they
now have to travel for flights they have
to spend money on airfare which is not
core to that membership but it's
additional risk and the last one which
is still technically under risk but I
like to pull it out is inconsistency
so if you're thinking about okay if I
said I can get you this this thing this
outcome all the things that make it suck
are the delay the effort the sacrifice
the risk and the inconsistent sometimes
it works sometimes it doesn't work my
Wi-Fi is spotty my like what makes you
hate your cell phone the most if 95% of
the time your cell phone worked and 5%
it didn't you would hate your cell phone
you would literally hate it if one out
of 20 times it wasn't working you check
your phone 20 times an hour if once an
hour your phone didn't work you would
want to throw it against the wall and so
a phone is an amazing product imagine
all the things we can do but just having
that little 5% inconsistency and the
business owner of the phone's like what
are they talking about this thing does
the internet it does this it does that
but just one out of 20 times you want to
kill somebody and so the Charlie Monger
had this quote which I love which
is the new business is sitting on your
desk in front of you it's the work in
front of you that's where the next
customer comes from and so I have I have
shifted my focus as an entrepreneur from
what are these opportunities that I
think I'm missing out on two how do I
just make the thing that I currently
have better and it's so painful because
it's not fun everything new is exciting
it's the woman in the red dress she
walks by she gets all your attention and
the thing is is that it's because you
don't know her backstory you don't know
the crazy ex-boyfriend you don't know
that she has chlamydia you don't know
all of these other things but everything
looks good when it's at a nightclub and
it's kind of dark and you're a little
bit buzzed right but the next morning
you're like oh my God there's some crazy
boyfriend knocking on the door she's
actually not single and oh my God why is
it burned when I pee and you've got all
these other issues that come with it
because you didn't know and so you have
uninformed optimism when you're looking
at missed opportunities you have
rosecolor glasses because all you see
now are the problems in your business
and you're like this thing would solve
all my problems this girl is the dream
girl I had it all wrong but it's not and
I'm telling you I've been so deceived by
this girl so many times which is why I'm
making this is that you just have to
keep looking and be like maybe the
reason that business isn't growing is
because I'm just not good enough is that
it's taking too long for my people to
get results it's too much work for them
it's too much sa they have to stop doing
the stuff they like it's too risky for
them to incur this and I'm not
consistent and if you use this as like
what are all the things that are that
are fall into these buckets and what you
do is you make your list one by one and
you go to your team and you say all
right these are all the things that are
messed up about our product
let's solve number one and we're going
to keep on number one until we solve it
and once we solve number one we're going
to go to number two and so if you're
curious about what the iPhone is the
iPhone is what's left after you remove
everything that sucks from a phone and
so you think about Steve Jobs in
creating valuable products it's very
difficult to know what is value but it's
very easy to know what's a problem and
when you remove all problems what you're
left with is value fifth problem that
[__] small business owners and this is
a big one all right so if you're like
more than one business isn't that the
woman in the red dress the answer is yes
so everything I just said applies to
that one overextension is what I need to
actually cover so overextension is where
you grow for the sake of growing sake
and so that's when you have one location
and then you think oh okay I finally
have this one going I'm going to open a
second location but as soon as you open
your second location all of a sudden the
profit from your first location drops
and so then what happens is now you're
doing twice the amount of work as you
were doing before but you're making the
same amount of money and then you think
okay well now this is the model this is
where this is the this is stasis so I'm
open a third location and so then you
open a third location and both of your
first two locations go down just a
little bit more and so now you're
working at three locations doing three
times the work but now you make zero
dollar in profit and anytime you've
unexpected expense it comes out of your
pocket and so you're like how did I get
here you got here because of
overextension and so overextension is
actually as a two-prong problem number
one is is entrepreneurs have arbitrary
timelines so and I so funny I talked to
a lot and I asked them what their goals
are and often times the you know they
the guys who are at uh you know 10K
month say they want to get to 30 guys at
30 say they want to get to 100 guys at
100 say they want to get to 200 guys at
you know 200 say they want to get to a
million whatever right everybody just
just does whatever the next Notch is and
so what's interesting is that although
that is a is a it's a noble goal there's
nothing wrong with making more money all
for it is that you want to be good
enough to earn the growth more than say
I will demand the growth by just
forcing more Revenue through the
business by just adding [__] on and this
can either be through adding products
that you shouldn't be selling or adding
service lines that you don't need to or
in the brick and mortar example starting
to add locations before you're ready now
if you're like well how do I know I'm
ready so the litmus test that I have
I'll give you the brick-and mortar one
but you can translate it uh pretty much
in any business is that the business has
to go for six
months without you and it has to
maintain or grow in that period of time
and so a lot of people think especially
if you're a smaller business owner and
you're getting to this point where
you're like oh I'm starting to grow is
because you remove yourself from
delivery and maybe sales and you're like
my business makes money without me
you've just never been a manager or
director or an operator before but you
probably work almost every hour of every
day and somehow you're not selling and
you're also not delivering then what are
you doing all day you're absolutely
working you're just in a higher leverage
job and so to think that oh this
business runs without me well no because
if you're not there it goes to [__] it
just the customers you're no longer
customer facing doesn't mean that you
don't work anymore like imagine imagine
what a big Fortune 100 company that all
of a sudden the entire seae leaves and
says oh well this business runs without
me it would very quickly crater because
no one is setting the objectives no
one's setting priorities no one's
driving accountability throughout the
organizations no one's aligning
resources to getting outcomes and so of
course what you do is still important
and of course what you're doing is still
work and so the trade that I I give I
walk people through this uh emotionally
I say this so if you want your location
to work right and you want to pass this
liit test here's the first and easy one
go on vacation for two to four weeks and
just say I'm turning my phone off okay
that's that's level one test level two
test is that after someone passes level
one you go to the manager of your
location or whatever and you say hey I'm
going to give you the opportunity to be
a co-owner in this business okay over
the next however many years uh you're
going to get 2% a year for the next five
years up to 10% cool and I'll give you
the profit share now and you can get the
equity later whatever I'm not going to
get in the deal structure but you say
here's the deal you get this profit this
phone doesn't ring that's the trade and
so let's role play it a pipe bursts what
do you
do if your first inclination is call me
that's not the deal what do you think
I'm going to do I'm going to call a
plumber and that's what you should do
and so I have a a
mentor uh my godfather um who said this
to me and I just love this so I called
him once out of the blue and um he said
what's wrong is everything okay that's
how he answered the phone and I was like
yeah everything's fine um he's like so
it's not an emergency I was like no he's
like then why are you calling me and so
basically he's like if you said it's an
emergency call 911 if it's not an
emergency why are you calling me and so
either way don't call me and so we were
we were playing tongue and- cheek he's a
great guy that's not the point but the
point is when you're having the
discussion with somebody to truly
delegate you have to be able to give the
control away otherwise you don't pass
the test that's if you have a brick and
mor location where you need to nail the
model before you scale it if you have a
call it service-based business then you
want to get the economics of your core
business working such that you do have a
profit and so if you're not profitable
and then you say oh I'll then add
something else on top in order to become
profitable I don't think that's the
right solution unless since day one
you're like oh I'm going to sell soda
and burgers and sodas where I make my
money that's a little bit different but
if you need to sell something else in
order to be profitable there's something
wrong with your core business and you
should just fix that rather than try to
add more and more stuff to your already
failing business and so if you're
curious like what's the solve to this
overextension let me tell you what the
solve is it's three letters w h o who
typically you have a who problem if you
want to do this expansion you want to
open the next location you want to do
this new product line or service line
you typically need to have a who who
either owns that new thing while you can
maintain the current thing or who can
take over the current thing so that you
can grow and take on the new thing but
in either instance overextension occurs
when you don't have a good enough who
and then you decide to do it
anyways and that's because of
greed there's no like there's really no
other there's really no other one or
Envy because you're competing with
somebody else and you think that you
just arbitrarily need to increase your
increase how much revenue because it
fills some hole inside of you which I'm
all for Success filling that hole but uh
at least do it well the amount of
overextension I saw at gym launch is was
is second to none we'd fix a gym and
then literally like I had this
happen lovely lady named um um was two
months from closing her gym signs up for
gym launch 30 days later she's got a
full gym and in 90 days from the time
that she signed up which remember is two
days from her shutting two two months
away from her shutting her doors she
then signs another lease for a second
location and I was like in what world
did you think that was a good idea she's
like well I'm already full it's like
yeah but you you've just been full for
the first time ever and you had to hire
new trainers which aren't who you didn't
train and you have all these backend
processes you don't even know what your
conversion on the back end is going to
be you don't even know your what your
turn rates are you have no I'm it's I'm
I'm going to give foreshadowing for the
next the next problem right um You have
no insert next problem you have to get
this stuff in place you have to
stabilize the business and so a lot of
people they they like they struggle
struggle struggle they see one thing is
success and they immediately think oh
I'm I'm therefore I'm successful I'm 10
Xing and if you measure on a longer time
Horizon you feed your ego in the short
term and you empty your bank account in
the long term which brings us to drum
please uh big risk number six which is
no this a big one wait for it no data
daddy wait why is Daddy included I don't
know you guys are weird but no data
daddy is the problem this is the the
thing that syncs the business and so let
me I want to describe what it feels like
when you don't have data if you were
constantly confused if you don't know
what you should do you typically don't
have data you have no tracking in place
you don't know where your customers come
from you don't know what your sales
conversion rate is you don't know what
percentage your customers stay after X
period of time you don't know what your
turn is you don't know what your gross
margins are and so you're trying to make
these decisions with no data and you
feel like you're an idiot but you're not
I can't make decisions without data no
one can I mean you can you're just
guessing and the thing is is that
guessing is a pretty bad way of making
decisions it basically states that
rolling a dice is the most effective way
to get an outcome and it certainly isn't
if you have a goal and so I mean you
will get an outcome it just probably
won't be the one you want it's assuming
Randomness is better than thought and so
if your thoughts are so poor that
Randomness is better then
entrepreneurship is never going to work
out for you anyways all right and so I
bring this up just to say that if you
don't know what to do data first and the
reason that entrepreneurs get stuck here
remember I talk about the rock in the
hard play scenario is that they feel
like they need to make more money they
feel like they need to be making more
profit they feel like they need to get
more leads all of these things
right and this feels non Revenue
generating and so you think well I got
to go get I got to go make this money uh
and the short-term pain is oh I got to
go collect a bunch of stuff and like get
get attribution in place I got to like
have an Excel sheet that like I got to
get my team to like say how many people
walked in today or how many clicks we
got to the website or what our
conversion rate is on our Pages well God
that's going to take so much time but I
need to do this rock in a hard place I
can promise you you're never going to
scale with that data it's never going to
happen but you can absolutely maintain
your very very terrible existence for a
very long period of time without any dat
and you're always wondering what's going
on wondering when the next shoe's going
to drop wondering where your next lead's
going to come from and what's
astonishing is when I had Al in the
software company we had these T t-shirts
that said data is dope um and data is
dope because you'd be amazed at how
intelligent people will perceive you to
be based on the quality of your
decisions when you have high quality
data because decisions tend to become
very easy when you have data
if you know that one Revenue stream
generates 80% of your revenue and the
other one's 20 and it's 80% of your
effort what do you do well obviously you
do this one yeah but people don't do
that why because they don't have the
data to see that if you have one one
channel where you're getting the most
profitable and best customers from and
you've got another one that you spend
80% of your time on and You' be like
well obviously I'll put my attention
where yeah but you don't know that and
so this is the thing is is like you will
look like a genius from the outside but
you're just making Common Sense
decisions and so most of business growth
is common sense
the problem is that most people don't do
the first and obvious thing of Common
Sense which is collect
data track and so I I I used to tell
this to the sales team and I actually
used it from when I had weight loss
customers I said if you don't track you
don't care and it's just like one of the
easy like you don't record your sales
calls you don't care if you don't track
what your Clos rates are you don't care
if you don't track what your profit is
you don't care and so I'm going to I'm
going to give you a term right now that
I I want you to write down if you're uh
if you're at home which is measurement
as inter
vention and so there's been countless
studies done on this but I'll give the
simple one which is in weight loss if
you want to help someone lose weight you
can truly tell them nothing besides just
getting them to weigh themselves every
day and when people weigh themselves
every day they lose weight
wild if you track your profit every
month guess what will happen your profit
will improve if you track your closeth
rate and you weren't tracking it it will
improve because you will be able to use
common sense because you able to see oh
when I did these on these sales calls my
close rate went up because you track it
and so if you want to improve any
component of the business the first step
is
measure and so I can't it's I mean I'm
embarrassed to say some of the size
business businesses that I've seen $5
million a year sometimes $10 million a
year who barely have simple data and so
if you're like well what data should I
collect because there's so much data
that's out there so let me answer that
question you want to collect the
pipeline and that goes from click to
close all right this is the first
pipeline that you need to track which is
at every point of conversion I've got a
you know what's my ctrr on my ads are my
content how much track traffic am I
getting what's my opt-in rate what's my
schedule rate what's my show rate what's
my offer rate what's my close rate
what's my cash collected all of these
those are all the metrics you track but
that's one funnel you have another
funnel that goes from
close to resell which is okay now that
I've closed somebody what's the
likelihood that they buy again or Ascend
into something else and so we're going
to have what's our activation what's our
time to Value what's our what's churn
what's what's grow gross profit per
product line what are Ascension rates by
cohort meaning what types of customers
choose what types of products and so you
want to have like if you had to do one
you do this one if you got two I would
say do this one if you had to do three
then I would start looking more front
end in terms of channels like where are
my leads coming from and
so one of these is probably the problem
in your business start tracking that one
first and if if you have problems on all
of these then track them all and that is
the first objective because from there
you can then actually improve it and
tracking itself and to rewind to the um
to the to the irrational belief of well
well I have to do this Revenue
generating activity I can't take time to
do this
data getting the data May in and of
itself already solved the problem for
you because you actually started paying
attention to it so as promised at the
beginning those are the six Horsemen
that plague businesses on a regular
basis I want to then translate this into
the real world by walking through a real
example of a portfolio company uh over a
year of
the data of this specific business now
I'm only going to share the backend data
because I did a different uh breakdown
on a YouTube video of the frontend data
of this business that we turned around
and so the first thing that we collected
was profit so the profit of the business
at the time
before it's 5% that's a terrible five
there we go 5% Revenue retention was
around 2% might as well be zero and then
you have ascensions which is what
percentage of customers and these are
interrelated obviously because if you
ascend customers they're more likely to
keep paying you by the way Pro tip if
you sell someone something else they are
more likely to pay you uh and so they
were getting zero to one per month and
this was a company that was selling you
know tens if not just under a 100 units
a month so like this this business had
um volume right so let's walk through
what we did to unfuck this business so
let's list out the problems and you'll
recall that the problems will not
manifest the way I described all right
so this is be this will be how you can
merge the reality with the theory uh
behind the problems all right so the
first thing is we got
churn and to be clear this is team churn
not customer turn this is employee turn
so people were leaving second was no
data that one's actually word for word
the exact same thing as the front next
is no Revenue retention so people
weren't staying and paying a year later
and then no
ascensions people weren't buying again
again now originally you'd think maybe
this product sucked um but we felt
really confident that it didn't because
the people who were buying were happy
with it and so we're like okay there's
some sort of misconnect which is usually
what I'm good at fixing so let's start
with the employee turn so they had two
issues that were big ones so number one
is that they were actually the reverse
of the other situation they were
actually
underpaying and because they were
underpaying they couldn't get good
calent into the business and I'll say
often times this is more common than the
undercompensation issue that I
referenced earlier it's just that this
one's easy to fix the overcompensation
problem is significantly harder because
you got to pull something back that was
once there and so what happens is when
you underpay people one is you're going
to get underqualified people and if you
do get qualified people they'll often
just take side work or second jobs in
order to make a full income for
themselves and then you really have half
of an employee and so uh not ideal and
so both of those situations that
occurred within the specific business
and the other problem with this
underpayment is that they had a poor
leader and so they had this was
specifically over the delivery
department and so that poor leader uh
ended up Believe It or Not uh trying to
push the entire department against the
founder uh and pit them against them and
almost blew up the entire business and
so we would consider this an existential
risk so those were the problems let's
talk about the solutions so number one
is we hired a new uh CS leader
unsurprisingly somebody who's more
experienced that didn't hate the founder
you'd be amazed at what happens when you
take out people who hate the founder and
hate the business and it turns out that
businesses grow better when the people
don't hate them who work there um the
second thing we did and this is in lock
step with what we're just saying is we
actually fired 90% of the Baseline team
and that was because we had hired the
wrong people um and they were those
basically cop was too low it attracted
the wrong people those people were bad
and we didn't think we could upskill
them and it basically wasn't worth the
resources we'd have to deploy in order
to fix it and so it's like hey it would
be faster for us to just restart and
reboot this department number three is
that with a reboot we hired super
aggressively uh to
backfill aggro hiring having a good CS
leader requires a number of things so
this type of person tends to be more
operational focused they're good with
details they're good at remembering
things um they love customers and their
focus is on value creation and so the
opposite of that is if your head of Cs
blames customer customers on a
consistent basis complaining is not a
strategy nor is blaming customers
because neither of those make you better
and basically taking zero accountability
for customer outcomes and typically they
are the type of people who also blame
team for a lack of outcomes as well and
so basically you've just got a big
victim like a true CS leader is a leader
they are accountable they hold
themselves accountable they hold the
team accountable and ultimately they
want to deliver value and that's all you
want someone who's customer obsessed who
like when you're about to say hey I
think we should do this thing they're an
advocate for the customer on now
obviously not to the degree that they're
like hey we should go out of business
give everything away for
free no but you should have somebody
who's got a heart for that and more is
aligned with the idea that hey if these
guys like if we can get them to pay more
we can give them more even more value
because they believe in the product and
they believe in the company now a good
Telltale sign of a CS leader is that
they're they're immediately willing to
jump in roll their sleeves up and talk
to customers not to say that's their
full-time job or that they're going to
do that like they're going to be taking
CS calls as their main thing but
especially if you're going to try and
turn around a department and sometimes
this is you you got to hop in there you
got to talk to your customers so you can
understand what's going on right and so
you know Steve Jobs like the best
entrepreneurs in the world still always
do this you're never too big to talk to
your customers so the next thing is is
after we hired the new CS leader he did
an assessment of the team and saw that
the majority of them were lacking skills
and he determined that it would not be
worth the resources to try and train
these people now he didn't then say
great now let's fire them all and screw
the business that wasn't actually what
happened so think about it like this um
let's say you've got a pot right with
water and this water is really diluted
so it's empty right so what he did was
he said hey I'm going to add
more green dye into here and when I add
that green dye I'm going to have like a
light green Hue and so he brought in
some good people at new and better
compensation who had more experience
doing doing this particular CS role that
was a better fit for this business and
now we had some good people and some bad
people but the good people were so
clearly the ones who were driving the
outcome willing to work harder willing
to roll up their sleev cared about the
customers that one of two things
happened a lot of these uh empty empty
water the diluted water uh exited
voluntarily they said you know what this
isn't for me anymore I don't want to
work this much blah blah blah blah blah
and then what ended up happening is that
long term the entirety of the team
basically became became these new people
that we got in and so because of that
we're able to shift the entire
concentration of the team without
disrupting the business and and to be
clear that means for a short period we
had to pay two teams we had to pay the
old team that sucked and the new team
that was good who would then jump in and
then the bad team which we already knew
were bad were happy to slack a little
bit more and so then it's basically what
what a lot of employees don't realize is
that they think that if someone else
comes in and makes their job option
leete it means that they're getting a
free check but what it really is it's
the warning sign that you're on the way
out the door you just don't know it
someone's covering for you before you
get fired and so the next question that
might naturally come up is like well
shoot how did they hire aggressively so
in terms of ordering probably is three
and then two so apologies there in terms
of the sequence of my little notes here
um but in terms of hiring aggressively
number one is we increased comp so we
paid people better and so what do you
know more people responded to the job
post responded to the reach outs um we
looked for csms with experience so these
were people who had already done a job
like this at a company of this size
before for this type of product crazy
crazy and we were looking for three plus
years for this particular um for this
particular business and the third thing
that we did was we increased Benny's not
Benjamin's uh but benefits all right so
we gave them uh pay time off and we
added you know full compensation
benefits on top of uh the salary and the
money you know the cial compensation and
so basically we just made an
irresistible offer a grand slam offer if
you will but to higher employees and so
if you are struggling right now to fill
up a new team or you have a constraint
in the business you're like I need to
hire new sales guys or I need to have
more CS or I need to have more whatever
right and you're not getting a lot of
lead gen you just got to look at your
offer you got to look at the you got to
look at like an ad it's like what's the
headline what's the what's the comp
what's the you know is it remote or in
person is it full-time is it parttime
what are the working hours uh what are
the benefits what are the expect ations
and you have to make sure that it's
reasonable if you asking for 10 years of
experience and you're starting
somebody's salary at at 50k it's
probably unlikely that like for almost
any role it's really unlikely that
you're going to get somebody and so you
need to make sure that you're matching
the requirements to the compensation a
good question that will come up around
CS or customer success or customer
service is do you compensate them around
ascensions or renewals um it really
depends on the business and so if
there's a call it a sale that's involved
uh where they have to get on the phone
and like sell a customer into it there's
typically going to be some sort of
compensation there if it's something
that happens more automatically in the
background they might have a percentage
of a book of business I generally don't
like that um I've noticed that people
tend to get a little bit complacent uh
when they just have like recurring
Revenue that they're not really
responsible for and so um if there's if
it's more sales heavy then typically
there will be a commission if it's less
sales heavy I would advise against it so
the first problem that we saw was
Employee turn so let's check that puppy
so now let's move on to no data no data
daddy zero data for me to tell you all
the data they didn't know I mean there's
unlimited amounts of data that they
could potentially collect but I'll just
give you some of the The Hot List all
right so this is just directly from my
notes so they didn't know what their
engagement rates were they didn't have
any customer satisfaction or NPS scores
they didn't even know the date that
customers were starting um they didn't
have throughput on the funnel uh in
terms of what closers are doing well
they didn't so they didn't have closed
rates by closer um they didn't even have
a grand new le like to the week um
customer segments were not existent as
in we didn't see like what types of
customers are buying what types aren't
um we didn't know what our refund rates
were uh we didn't know what payment
plans looked like in terms of managing
cash flow in the business like we didn't
know what churn was we didn't know what
Ascension rates were we didn't know what
the time to Value was we didn't know
what activation points were like I could
keep going they basically they didn't
didn't know a lot about about their own
business you'd be amazed at how easy
some of the things that you can do are
once you see what the problems are
because the thing is that the data will
scream at you it will become patently
obvious like if you're not making money
the data will will obviously show you
why you're not making the first thing we
did was we wanted to fix the front end
stats around sales because remember I
said click the close you got to get that
and so I talked about that at more
length in a different video but we
figured out close rates in General close
rates by closer close rates by time
period um and by cohort all right so we
got that stuff off the bat done now the
second set of problems with this is more
backend related uh was related to
customer you know CS right and so um
number one is we looked at time to Value
like was there some sort of Milestone
that we could help them achieve sooner
in their customer Journey the second was
tto which is time to onboarding okay so
how quickly from the time someone
purchases until they're live or active
this is one of the easiest ways that you
can drive value like how are these
different well sometimes the time to
Value happens after the onboarding
sometimes it happens during the
onboarding sometimes you have multiple
points of value but this one obviously
has to happen as fast as humanly
possible so time to value is going to be
typically an activation point and so an
activation point is some sort of
activity that occurs that is a high
correlation with them staying or paying
later and so if you're like well how do
I know that the easiest way to do that
is look at the people who are currently
staying in paying and look at what they
did earlier and then try and reverse
engineer that outcome for everyone and
so for example if you find out that uh
you know customers who join a gym uh and
attend three workouts a week for their
first uh actually I think Orange Theory
they actually figured out their
activation point which was five workouts
in the first month and so when they
found out that one metric was that if
someone worked out five times in the
first month the likely that they'd stay
for the next like eight was
significantly higher and so then all of
their onboarding process was then geared
towards driving that activation point
and by the way this is most of what
onboarding is and this is why data so
important if you knew for example that
every customer who gets their first you
know one sale so for gym launch like we
knew that if somebody got a $22,000 sale
at a gym within their first seven days
they were worth three times more to us
as as a business owner and so what do
you think we did we did everything in
our power to get the $2,000 sale in the
first seven days that's what we did and
so it becomes You' be like well what do
you do it's like well once you have the
data it becomes pretty obvious what you
do right you try and do more of that
thing that worked and so this is this is
where like the the the extra brain cell
the second brain cell has to turn on and
this is where you say what are all my
successful customers look like what did
they do and then how do I get all my
customers to do that on purpose instead
of on accident if you're very
sales-oriented or promotional founder
like if I if you take one thing from
this whole video it's that you want to
create a really beautiful onboarding
process like if you had only one thing
to take away it would be onboarding like
you fix turn through onboarding and a
lot of this is expectation setting
relative to goals and so sales hands off
a customer to a customer success and in
the onboarding you want to restate their
goals multiple times so that they know
that you know what their goals are and
then you tie their goals to the actions
or activities that you want them to take
which typically should be aligned with
the time to value and so think about it
like this in General most businesses
that are well-designed should have their
value creation which is what they get
paid for aligned with the customer value
creation and so you in a very beautiful
way have an aligned incentive with the
customer if they want to make money
because you're B2B then you want to make
them money too and you should clearly
state in order for us to have you hit
this goal you need to do these five
things and when you do these five things
it increases the likely that this money
occurs and if this money occurs it means
that it's more likely that you pay me
and that you stay happy so the next
thing that we looked at the next thing
that we had to start tracking was
customer engagement and so customer
engagement is in a software setting it
would be usage which is you know how
frequently are people commenting inside
of the group are they attending calls
are they attending their check-ins with
their reps are there Milestones or
achievements um all of these things are
things that indicate engagement and so
the shorthand for customer engagement is
use are they using it because I mean
think about the logical extreme if
someone doesn't use anything they're
going to turn and if someone uses it all
the time it's less likely they're going
to turn and so figuring out what the
activation point is is looking at all of
the things people use and figuring out
what few things they use that have the
highest correlation with staying and so
if you have 10 things that customers
could potentially do in the business
there might be three of them that are
the ones that are the core value
creators which then have the highest
correlate with them actually staying
long term and I'll give you a little a
little a little Advanced business tip
for you A lot of times if you want to
improve the quality of a product product
or service it actually comes from
deletion not addition and so as humans
we often want to overd deliver in value
and so we think oh we need to add more
stuff but the number one reason that
people cancel or turn across across
Industries is overwhelm there's too much
stuff to do and so the result of that is
what are all of the things that we can
remove and so I'll give you a very
tactical way to do this I want you to
write out a list of every single feature
that you have in your services now when
you actually do this you'll realize that
you have a lot more things that you give
people than you realize you probably
have downloads you might have calls you
might have events you might have uh you
might have some sort of chat support you
might have all you also have the core
deliverable you have all these things
that you do put a big list out and then
ask them this magical
question if I got rid of
everything except
one
thing
which
would you
want to
keep and so you have that list below and
when when people are forced to say like
if you could only keep one thing what
would it be you will have a very clear
idea of the things that drive the most
value now you might you might initially
think oh everyone's going to pick this
just send the survey and you will be
surprised some people stay for very
different reasons but it will give you a
power ranking of one two and three that
are the most valuable and then if you
want to go to the 301 Advanced business
move look at the one that was the lowest
value and then remove it and don't tell
people you remove it just remove it and
see who complains and if no one
complains congratulations you just got
to make the same money for doing less
and if people do complain look at who's
complaining and are they the types of
businesses or customers that you want to
serve and so sometimes you will get some
complainers but they may be the worst
customers that you've been planning on
getting rid of anyways and you're like
great let's get rid of them too why not
and so um I'll give you a little story
about this so I ran this survey uh at
gym launch years ago and we had a lot of
things that we were doing for our
customers and one of them is that we had
real-time tech support and so we had a
35 person team that did tech support for
the gym owners because it's one of the
one of the biggest obstacles people kind
of encounters they're not good with like
how do I install pixel how do I make a
landing page all that kind of stuff the
lowest one of the lowest ranked things
was this tech support team and I after
seeing it I was like oh my God this is a
massive department so I interviewed a
couple customers and they were like yeah
I don't really care either way like
that's not the the main the main value
driver and so I deleted the department
which is a very nice way of saying that
I released people to free free agency 35
it was terrible was honestly it was a
horrible experience um um but here's
what happened to our churn and our sales
nothing they added no value and so Carl
icon tells a story about this where he
bought a company and there was an entire
building in a state and I can't remember
what state it was and it was like 11
stories of just this company just like
one one huge you know division of this
business and he said he he spent months
analyzing trying to figure out what
anyone did there and he would go there
and they would turn him six ways to
Sunday and say all the work that they do
was important and he was like I'm a
pretty smart guy and I have no idea what
you're doing and so he went to one of
the factories and he asked one of the
foremans he's like you know about these
guys and he was like dude just get rid
of them they don't do anything and so
after months and months and months he
decided to get rid of the entire 11
floors he did he fired everyone and he
said the weirdest thing happened nothing
he said I didn't even get an email this
was an entire a whole building full of
people who actually did nothing and so
the thing is is that we as entrepreneurs
often times think to have to solve
problems we add bodies and then bodies
tend to multiply because other people
tend to try and solve solutions by just
saying I'll hire more people and this is
where it gets even dumber is that one
people hire people stupider than them in
general as a rule of thumb because they
feel like they're in control and they're
not threatened which means that your
organization over time just gets dumber
and dumber and so you have to have
controls in place to prevent that and
number two so what happens is everyone
delegates their workload to dumber and
dumber people so it's like the director
gets something from a CEO and then and
says okay I'm just going to delegate
that to the manager and then the manager
gets in and says I'm going to delegate
it to the Frontline employee and then
the Frontline employee says hey I need
support because I can't do all this work
and then hires someone new and then
delegates it to them and so what was
supposed to be an incredibly important
thing just gets done by the most
incompetent person in the business and
that happens all the time and so to
prevent against that consistently asking
your customers where the value is being
provided is an excellent way to
determine whether or not values being
provided so the next thing that we
started to track was cessat or so cat is
customer satisfaction uh CAD for short
or NPS which is net promoter score so
these are the two scores that uh
acquisition. comom uses most frequently
in terms of uh to determine uh how well
you know product is delivering to its
customers and um NPS is the less
forgiving of the two and so I would weit
rate that higher and so for those you
who don't know how NPS score works it's
a uh it's a it's a negative 100 to a
positive 100 score so it's not a 0 to
100 so Zero's in the middle and I think
the average company has like a -2 uh in
terms of score just to give you context
and so uh you ask people How likely are
you to refer a friend to this business
and uh basically the answers go 10
through you know one and anything that
is a six or below is considered a
negative one crazy someone gives you a
six it's a negative 1 seven and8 are
both zeros and then only 9 and 10 are
plus one and so in order to get a 100
that means every single one of the
customers that you survey has to rate
you over an eight you cannot not get
anyone who's even a seven like a seven
would be a zero and so would it would
detract from your 100 a six would be
you'd have one of those plus ones would
be counted against and so uh it's one of
the most sensitive scores but because of
that I think it's one of the most
accurate um because it's such a
hypothetical ideal it's so hard it's
basically like to give you context apple
has a 61 all right so it's a very very
sensitive score um and so like
Chick-fil-A is a 58 just to give you a
context here in terms of like some
exceptional business is and how hard it
is and this is why I like this score
because you can kind of pump yourself up
with customer satisfaction scores but
NPS because it has the negatives and how
it weights is a very good way to
understand um how good you're actually
doing the next one is Ascension rates so
this is what percentage of customers who
buy the first thing go to the second
thing and you can do it by two two
metrics here you do qualified ascensions
which is what percentage of customers
who were qualified to ascend then
ascended and what percentage of total
customers um in toal Ascend this is more
valuable to understand how well you're
doing this is more valuable to
understand how the economics of the
business work and so if you know that
let's say uh you know 80% of customers
who are qualified Ascend but you're only
ascending 10% of customers then it means
we might be selling too many unqualified
customers or we might not be doing well
enough on our initial core product to
get them to the point of being qualified
and so having both of these metrics
gives you a a paired idea of a quantity
and quality metric so the next one that
we prioritized uh was was churn and you
if you've been on this channel you
should know what churn is by now but I
will I'll I'll give you the quick and
dirty so churn percentage is what
percentage customers from last month are
still here this month and so if I had
100 customers last month and I've got 95
of those 100 that are still here my turn
is 5% now if I sold 10 more clients that
doesn't matter it's how many of the
original customers I had last month are
still here one month one month later now
5% may seem good to you but here's
what's
crazy if you want to see what percentage
of customers you keep every year if you
have 5% monthly turn you're going to
lose over half of your customers every
year which means you have to sell half
the year just to break even on your
growth very hard to out sell bad turn
turn varies a lot by industry by the
nature of the product and obviously the
quality of the product like there's
lower turn in alarm systems than there
is in online groups right and so uh you
know there's lower turn in you know
internet providers there's there's a lot
of industries that just have that are
more prone to stickiness and they tend
to be honestly uh products that work
without the customer doing anything and
so think about what what products are
like that so like Insurance Works
without you doing anything your solar
roof Works without you doing anything
your Wi-Fi works without you doing
anything your your your cell phone
carrier works without you doing anything
and so they call this in the software
word magical products it's like they you
only notice when they're not working and
so those are wonderful products to be
able to build whenever you see those
types of opportunities but for this
particular business it required work on
behalf of the customer so it's naturally
going to have higher turn uh but this
was one of the big things that we had to
be able to start tracking because guess
when you start tracking it it starts
getting better if you want to use turn
as a benchmark you can just Google uh
industry Benchmark turn
4X um and you'll usually get some sort
of stats that'll be decent at least
it'll give you directional data um and
also just talking to competitors talking
to other people you know trade
conferences things like that can give
you very good data of like oh you know
what I have 5% ger but everyone's at 15
so I'm actually doing okay um now I
don't care too much I want to like just
put this out there I don't care too much
about everyone else does because like I
just want to win and so if I'm like
winning by a lot i' just still rather
win by more um so the next one is uh and
the last one was client goals and so
this uh was important because so the
next thing we tracked was was customer
goals so this is a qualitative data
point and this should be something that
is one captured on the sales call it's
also reminded or reiterated on the
onboarding call it should be something
that's updated on a regular basis
because client goals change and so we
want to make sure that all of the people
who are touching the customer weirdos um
know what the current goal of the
customer is and so if you're doing a
good job you might help them accomplish
this goal so you might have to set
another goal and so if you remember the
whole point of of getting someone
motivated to take any kind of action is
you have to create some sort of
deprivation between where they are and
where they want to be right so they want
to be up here celebrating yay right and
they're over here and they sad faces is
that we just have to like as soon as
they get happy be like no no no you
should be sad even though we cut your
turn from 10% to 5% you should be at two
and a half percent right you just keep
moving the goal post just like you do
for yourself just do it for them so uh
no Daya Daddy no we are actually not
fatherless we indeed have a father
father we have father data so next we
have uh basically no renewals we have no
Revenue retention so if I looked at 100
customers this year and I looked at 100
customers next year the likel that they'
be the same people is zero no one no one
is renewing so that's obviously an issue
because think about like this if you
have a business that you don't renew any
customers here I'll I'll walk you
through a visual example so let's say
you've got two businesses all right and
you've got you know year one year two
and year three and let's say at the end
of year three both of these businesses
have 300 active customers okay now
business
one uh loses 100% of its customers every
year that means that year one it sells
100 customers year two it has to sell
200 customers and then year three in
order to have three 300 it has to sell
all 300 that year so in order to scale
that business you just have to scale
acquisition you have to get more leads
you have to get more salesman and you
just have to keep scaling the front end
now let's look at business 2 so business
too and let's say that they sell 100 as
well but they have 100% customer uh
annual renewal so next year they sell
plus 100 but they have 200 customers
total and then the third year they have
plus 100 but they have 300 customers
total so both of these businesses have
300 customers three years later but
which business would you rather have
well I'll tell you which one I would
rather have I would rather have this one
because I know that if I just keep doing
this I'm just going to keep being able
to grow this business to grow this
business I know that at year four in
order to grow I'm going to lose all 300
of these and I got to sell 400 customers
next year just just to grow a little bit
just to grow by
25% and so this is why when you're
building a business everybody's in a
rush but being in a rush is what ensures
that it takes much longer for you and so
you you're you're here you're losing all
your customers but you learned how to
sell congratulations but by doing that
you never solve the main problem and
then that problem that churn issue that
Revenue retention issue will become a
monster that in the beginning it's a
little little nibble but then it just
bigger and bigger and bigger and you
don't want to feed that monster so the
reason that they had no Revenue
attention beyond the fact they didn't
even track it was that they had no
script for how their customer
interaction should should be they had no
prioritization of customers
overall the uh there these conversations
were having at random not on any sort of
cadence ascensions were ad hoc meaning
basically only if a customer reached out
to them and said hey can I buy the other
thing they're like oh yeah sure but
there was no journey to drive people
towards that that
outcome so this is what we did to fix it
and so for the purpose of this I'm going
to break renewals and ascensions into
two different things renewals are they
buy the same thing again ascensions are
they buy something even either more
quality or more quantity all right and
so for the renewal process uh we did
number one we started tracking time to
value and so crazy is if you actually
provide more value to people faster and
you track it they are happier the second
thing is that we contextualized uh
conversation so um we had notes on every
customer we installed a note system
basically so that every time a rep would
talk to a customer they had the history
of the customer's past conversations and
so one of the easiest ways to piss off a
customer is to have them repeat
themselves and so as I was alluding to
earlier you want to think about all the
stuff that sucks about an experience and
remove all the friction and so repeating
yourself would be friction and so if you
want to have an exceptional experience
just remove everything that sucks the
third thing we did is we reframed the
renewal in the context of their goals
so basically we're like hey you want
this big goal renewing is the way that
you get there and so a lot of people
didn't know that it sounds silly but
like we didn't say hey your goal is this
this gets you to your goal you should
buy it just as simple as that is and all
of these things build in each other so
when you have the time to Value you know
what you're driving everyone towards
when you have the notes then you can
talk to them and personalize the
experience that they're having on a
regular Cadence and then when we have
the context and we know where we're
driving them towards then we can speak
in terms of their goals to get them to
be more likely to renew
and then finally here's the brilliant
one we said when and where have they
renewed most frequently in the past and
it turned out for this business that
they would have these Live Events every
so often and at the Live Events they had
a huge amount of renewals that would
happen and we said what if instead of
having these happen on accident we had
them happen on purpose instead of them
happening randomly we had them happen
regularly and so when we did that we got
way more people to regularly Ascend by
driving them to the highest converting
event that we had for renewals and so
think about it instead of saying like
hey we're going to have a customer
appreciation event once a year maybe you
do one once a quarter and you actually
choreograph the event a little bit so
that you have a sales outcome and so
survey says for Revenue retention huz
that's what we did all right so for this
particular business for Ascension so I
just covered how we got every people who
were buying called six to 12 months of
service to buy another six or 12 months
of service the second part was can we
get them to ascend to a higher uh level
of service for this business and so
their Ascension process was just as
disorganized Andor non-existent as the
renewal process so there was no script
there was no prioritization of customers
that we thought these ones would be a
good fit these ones wouldn't be a good
fit it was random and and at the at the
point that we started decide to fix this
all ascensions what 100% of ascensions
came from only one closer who just
happened to be a superstar closer and
was just in touch with their Pipeline
and so they would close somebody and
then they would just shoot him a random
text six months later and be like hey uh
you want to buy this next thing and that
was how they were getting their
ascensions and so here was the brilliant
idea that we had now I've talked about
this uh before but some people forget
and some people need to be reminded
which is that whenever you make a sale
so let's assume this is the point of
sale this is when you make your first
transaction at this point there are four
or five opportunities that you can have
to basically make ascensions occur so
one is immediate so that's like 24 hours
you just immediately upsell them that
does work the next is um at some sort of
time to Value so some immediate quick
Value Point the next is the halfway
point so just arbitrarily if you have
some sort of defin in thing for whatever
reason halfway feels like a great time
for people to do it and so you can to
send them the halfway point the next is
if you have some big milestone that they
achieve so if you have some more
aspirational so think this is like uh
you get a first first win and this is a
big win so this is a first win this is a
big W all right so these are kind of
like two different they're somewhat
similar but uh different in same in
spirit different in practicality and
then finally here you have your last
chance which is usually not when you
want to do this and believe it or not
most people try and get all of their
ascensions here which is why they don't
make them and so I kind of think about
um ascensions and renewals like this
open loop okay and so if we have this
Loop that's see if I can draw this not
ugly so if we have this open loop that
opens as soon as you you make a purchase
or you make a sale I have this weird
belief that people basically close this
Loop and it's closing as they get to the
end of something and so we want to sell
them when it's most open and so we
basically want to keep the party going
rather than they're finish and then
they're like okay now I'm making another
purchasing decision you want them to be
in the middle of it and be like no we're
just going to kick it out we're just
keep it keep it going and this is why I
think we've been just exceptionally good
at um ascensions across all the
companies I've had as and I learned this
from weight loss when I had sixe
challenges I upsold people at 24 hours
and I upsold people at the halfway and I
upsold people at the at the end so I had
three upsell points in six weeks and so
if you think you're you're making like
again you're not hard closing you're
just making offers and you incentivize
the person to take the next step as long
as is align with their goal they'll take
it so the number one thing that we did
was that we aligned to the journey so we
actually created customer journey and
said at these points these trigger
closing calls so if you say that then
it's like okay well how do you make sure
that that actually happens so I told you
earlier that we typically don't do like
uh commissions unless it's
sales-oriented now this is a
sales-oriented business and so what we
did with this business is we actually
split it so the csms got money for sets
so they would identify a customer who
had reached one of these points because
they were the ones who were in touch
with the customers that makes sense
right and so they say hey I think you
should talk to Shawn Shawn can
definitely get you set up right and so
if they did a good pass off they got
money just for the intro then obviously
the closers would get commissions on the
sales right and so the result of both of
those things is that we went from 0 to
one per month happening randomly to 5 to
six per month so we five to 6X the
backend ascensions by simply saying
here's the journey these are the
Milestones when these Milestones occur
pass them to these guys that's it not
complicated but guess how you never find
out that this can happen you have no
data because you have no start dates you
don't know where people are at you have
know one who's tracked you have no goals
that are being reset and so this is why
data gives you the opportunities data
opens the doors for these other things
to occur afterwards and so for the
revenue of this business so is a higher
ticket B2B business uh this added an
extra $2 million in Revenue to the
business which drops almost just
disproportionately to bottom line so
added $2 million in IA just from doing
these things and so I don't know about
you but I think we Kaz got our
ascensions so we conquered the the six
things that get people screwed now this
this business didn't have all six but it
had a few of them and let's see what
actually happened in terms of the after
effect on the business so the profit of
this business went from 5% to 30% so he
6X woohoo the second thing we did is we
went from having no dat to having data
which I don't even have as a line here
but we had it the next thing is we went
from revenue attention being at 2% to
30% also ironically 30 is our magic
number for this business and then for
this business uh for ascensions we went
from 0 to1 to 5 to six per month so we
had a 6X here 6X here and by the way
there's a reason that those are related
let me walk you through some of the big
takeaways so that you can apply this to
your business so number one they had the
wrong who on the back end right so had a
cancerous leader who was there only for
status and didn't care about the
customers at all and just did it did the
job because they wanted a paycheck and
wanted to make their life as easy as
possible and only complained and had a
victim mindset so number one if you have
those people in your business just get
them out as fast as possible like the
best day to get rid of cancer is today
number
two the profit is disproportionately
made on the back end and I think that
the reason the businesses that I've had
you know over the years and continue to
have are typically disproportionately
profitable compared to other businesses
in the industry is that we focus so hard
on the back I typically build businesses
back to front I try and solve how do we
make this thing so unbelievably
profitable so that I can then outspend
everybody else on the acquisition and
that's fundamentally how I approach most
businesses at least once they get to
scale and so this business you saw the
difference that that occurred by fixing
the back end with renewals and
ascensions was a 6X increase in profit
now mind you they had had some tough
times which is why we got involved with
this particular business because we
thought that there was a big area of
opportunity and we obviously proved that
out pretty quickly I don't think this
took more than 90 days it was not a not
a big change
um but the stats I think I reported year
to year but these were uh these were
relatively fast changes that you can
make in a business the next thing is
that if you have no data you will never
improve anything I think I beat this
dead horse but if you don't know what to
do or you don't know how to grow your
business it's because you don't know
because you don't have data and so the
first and most obvious thing that you
have to get in place is tracking the
next one is that the founder typically
has to jump in you have to be
comfortable getting your hands dirty you
have to be comfortable rolling your
sleeves up and so that's both the new
hire who comes in who's the leader and
also the founder and so I think the
founder got a little bit too far away
from the business and I have this saying
that I like which is you want to know
where the bodies are buried and so if
you have anybody who rolls into you
inside of a business department and you
say hey how are things going and the
person's like ah things are good blah
blah blah if you as the founder or even
you if you're in an organization you're
just a director or leader if you don't
know where the problems are in every
person's Department who's reporting to
you or even any every individual who's
reporting to you you're too far away
because there's always bodies there's
always problems and if you don't know
what they are you're being an effective
leader and so that's how I that's how I
keep the the right amount of distance
for the things that I'm directly
involved in because we spent basically
this whole you know quarter or two
stabilizing the business driving up the
profit margin making sure that we
streamline this back end now we can
actually start scaling it and so I'll
just say this as somebody who owns a
portfolio of companies we spend as long
as it takes to get this right sometimes
it's 18 months sometimes it's sometimes
it's six months s it's two years and it
just takes what it takes but once you
like this is where a lot of Founders
want to scale like it's getting over
your skis right they overextend if this
particular founder had spent you know 10
times the money on Advertising it would
have been a calamitous event it would
have been horrible for the business
because all it would have done was
compounded a negative reputation because
they didn't have any processes in place
to get people great results and have a
wonderful experience and so if if
anything it's like you only Market to
let people know about your stuff but if
your stuff sucks you only want to let as
few people as possible no just to keep
the lights on right and so like I had
zero issue with you know our us ramping
down or just keeping stable on ad spend
um to keep this business just afloat uh
because you notice like the the the the
profit margin was really small in the
business but I was like that's fine I
don't care about breaking even right now
let's fix all this other stuff improve
the bucket fix all the holes then and
now we can pour as much as we want on
the front end and so now we know with
this business we have fixed costs that
as we add even more customers that
margin will actually continue to expand
and so fundamentally this is how we
unfuck businesses and uh I hope the six
that we uh that we outlined earlier you
can identify uh maybe one or two of them
that you're struggling with and if you
are in that boat you at least you know
how to fix them and so I just talked
about how we fixed the back end of this
business but we also fixed the front end
of this business and I went through a
full breakdown of this was a business
that sold via webinar uh to a sales team
and so we optimized every part of that
process on the front end which drove
huge results for the business and so if
you check that video out click